it's fall as you can tell looking out my
beautiful window it's fall BRR
don't let them fool you folks it's a
real window it's fall right now and all
across the world people come to the
Northeast to see the fall foliage people
come from all over they take buses up
there everyone wants to go to the Great
American northeast to New York to
Vermont to New Hampshire to see the fall
foliage because it's so incredible right
now and I thought we have to take
advantage of this it only comes along
once a year it only lasts about a week
we have to somehow show our audience
across the world because this is an
international show we have to show them
don't laugh at that we have to show them
the fall foliage we have to show them
all that stuff so I decided what I'm
gonna do is I found there's a really
nice apple orchard in upstate New York
and I thought what I'd do is I'd head up
there with a camera crew and I'd bring a
friend along and the two of us would
spend the day at the apple orchard in
honor of fall foliage we had a really
good time me and my Chum and well take a
look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
beautiful isn't it oh yes it's a great
mr. C mr. C I like that yes yes
definitely we go take some apples home
yeah we can take apples home whenever
you want you know in feed the homeless
yeah keep them for ourselves yes yes yes
a greedy person anyway mr. t I think
this looks like a pretty good tree right
here you like it Audrey yes sir it's a
good tree now I think instead of shaking
the tree or climbing up into the tree I
think if you just yelled at the tree the
apples might fall down you want to try
that cut you into pieces
I'm appeal you and I must get you then I
might eat the car I tell you the Apple
they don't fall down stop William -
you're overcome to see
mr. C mr. C I forgot mister feet ain't
working let's try something else I will
just try just picking them
conventionally come right here everyone
God didn't make little green apple he
goes
door all right doesn't favor yell at the
Apple for not being a good Apple
come on you know what's wrong with this
app you you yelled at it those are goose
bumps scare you probably right you
probably right in this little chili out
of here too you know you put the fear of
God into this Apple Wow
I shouldn't scare fruit I can't believe
it I can't believe it leave fruit alone
all right I'll leave foodie things alone
[Applause]
all right Johnny up we'll see
[Music]
see Linnea this is a bad tree man listen
don't get all the whole point is to be
out here and relax you get all worked up
so we found an apple of it but are you
no good man we gotta get good apples man
we can't make no apple pie with no bad
now but like they all right just breathe
breathe
let's get another round all right that's
a bad one
let me show you let me show you yelling
at the be alright dad bt1 b0 yelling at
me come on down calm you know it now I'm
gonna come down now that you're getting
mad again I don't think so no PR too
long I'm tired of waiting I'm gonna stay
up here until you're not mad anymore you
already get what you're getting mad dad
way down episode 18 no we thought
Hannibal had a good plan
oh man who's that the beets and stuff
like that we were trying to make a
submarine I was gonna planes I scared of
planes didn't like planes a man special
it crazy fool Murdock we be flying you
know it's the key that was the key
that's what everybody liked the show you
know because we never killed nobody
[Music]
ba Baracus be Halle mad Murdock dude had
a fight four guys for the crooks you
know in the henna pool and the rest of
guys there'll be a can take them there
was not famous or just punching guys out
I love that man
give me thrown apples now now we're
stuck it that way
oh yeah mom doc well that's what you got
new apples look go right there
what it's covering your mouth my mother
told me to come up with eating but you
yell at me all day in brother Raymond me
and then you cover your mouth we all
don't we eat without me yelling at you
my mother told me to cover my mouth when
I'm eating okay weird you've got you
know you get real mad scream and then
you cover your mouth you don't spit on
someone that's right come on polite
[Music]
well you better not
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the fun day thanks mr. t swim the ice
guy a lot of fun hanging around with